after the tragic Germanwings incident
the focus for airlines now shifts to
preventing situations in which a similar
event can occur the downing of the
flight seems to have been enabled by
measures taken after nine eleven to
fortify cockpit doors I'm pleased to say
joining us now for more is Thomas has
damaged director of operations at
norwegian the airline is among those
changing procedures so that a commercial
pilot cannot be left alone in the
cockpit Thomas great to have you with us
this morning to get some of your insight
I guess my first question would be to
you is that this has been a u.s.
requirement for a while why was Europe
behind the curve yeah I think you have
to actually direct that question to the
he also to the European rule fighters
because it is not it is not a law in and
a requirement from from those people so
but we have in Norwegian we have thought
about this for for a little while now
and actually when this was known as a
factor of the accident for two days load
and we decided to actually put a little
more pressure on what we already had
been working on so we we actually
implemented a new rule yesterday evening
stating that a cockpit crew member
should never be left alone in pocket
even this even always if the other
palette has to to leave for physical
needs or any safety reason so I
understand this has to await regulatory
approval what do the regulators actually
have to approve what would they be
worried about yeah difficult question I
butter seen from our point of view
living you know it is a general rule
that [ __ ] it should be operated by two
pilots and and one of them can
occasionally for for siskin beats or
safety reasons but thing is when that
harlot is alone he he has nobody to help
you nobody too
to look after him in a way because we we
can I don't think the suicidal
perspective is is very it's quite odd
Anna the thing which is more actually
more concerned this is fatigue or if the
pilot get incapacitated for some reason
and then I think it's vital that that
this other tasks somebody to happen to
get help into cockpit get the other
pilot into coffee that's the whole idea
Thomas as we go forward clearly
pilotless planes is something for
decades and decades ahead but it's the
way you look at things can we really
avoid any situation where actually we've
just got to put our trust in the guys
flying the plane you can't have an
override system from outside the plane
from say off land because even that
could be hacked into would you say that
actually we're just sort of point wait
you just need to trust the guys flying
the plane there's no other option
basically you're right I don't see any
option but so it when we pick our pilots
we definitely have to be careful of what
kind of pilots we are recruiting but but
I must also remind you that this is a
very odd situation so so the probability
for something happened is extremely low
but at the same time we as a company has
to do every means to to make sure that
we have the right guys on board of
sitting in cochranton and administrating
the fight